how did Stalin come to power if we
return back to
those early days post the October
Revolution with Lennon and Trotsky
and Stalin how did he come to power so
what Stalin did very cleverly Stalin was
you know he worked the system he was you
know but he was very much in the
background and what he did better than
trotsky's he was much more politician he
was a gladhander he made friends within
the party he made people feel respect
and appreciated uh and Len entrusted him
when after Lenin's stroke Stalin was
basically the one who was keeping track
of him Lenin asked Stalin at one point
for to kill him because after The
Strokes he was incapacitated style and
talked him out of it but at the same
time Lenin was like if I need someone
killed like this is who I need to talk
to you know Stalin if you look up photos
of him when he was young he was a stud
he was a gangster he's a bank robber uh
and
you know he basically worked the system
and you had the trotskyites on one hand
who were much more to the left Stalin's
big
I would guess I would call it a heresy
was he put forth the idea of socialism
in one country whereas like we're just
going to make it work here in what
became the Soviet Union the Trotsky idea
and this is really kind of the Marxist
idea is that the workers revolution has
to be worldwide uh this is just a
worldwide kind of new era of humanity
where Stalin's like no no we're just
gonna make it here and then later uh
behind what became the Iron Curtain but
this was sure this was an ideological
division between the two but what
happens in totalitarian countries it
happens in any kind of like you know
when you have intermingling of like
religion and government things that are
like ideological ideological disputes
like the Aryan heresy the Aaron Harris
and Christianity is that Christ is
subordinate to God the father right
whereas the Contemporary Orthodox
version it's three Gods one God and
three person excuse me so they're all
co-equal aspects of God in heaven but
that was an excuse to be like you guys
are evil you're on the side of the devil
we're going to kill you so these little
disputes about ideas are often a
convenient cover for people to have a
power struggle
in the guise of being like it's not that
I'm about wanting to be more powerful
I'm just on the side of the truth and
you're speaking lies and that's
dangerous to the revolution or to the
true Faith so he squeezed Trot but the
thing is Trotsky had the seeds of his
own defeat because pertrotsky the party
is always right you cannot be right
against the party right so if you have
this kind of party structure and the
party is saying you're wrong as an
individual you are wrong because the
collective is what makes decisions the
collective the workers are who have the
knowledge and and the information and it
is important for you to kind of
subordinate your selfishness your
individualism to this greater good so he
kind of set himself up in many ways
is it clear to you why Trotsky Lost That
Power struggle so you just explained
that he sets himself up but you can see
how different ideologies can be used to
uh to achieve different ends is there
another alternative possible trajectory
where Trotsky could have been the the
head of the Soviet Union uh it would be
very hard because he was Jewish so when
they were seizing power Trotsky
explicitly said I can't be in charge I'm
Jewish so the Soviet Union remained
extremely anti-semitic uh one of the
reasons so many Jews became Communists
in the Soviet Union because the promise
was once the Communists took over we're
not going to have pogroms anymore
programs was you had these Jewish
ghettos and under the permission or
encouragement of the Czar just gangs of
people go through killing raping robbing
stealing riding for days and just it
just it could be Massacre and the idea
is like under communism everyone's going
to be equal we're not going to have this
anymore they still had it but to a
lesser extent but uh
since Trotsky was Jewish his real name
is Lev bronstein you can't it was almost
impossible to have a scenario where he
was going to be in charge and Stalin fed
into that to some extent also this kind
of idea of Jewish internationalism it's
like okay he doesn't really have loyalty
to Russia and many of the people who
were Jewish who were high up in Stalin's
um uh government Administration they
very much had to prove their loyalty uh
to Communism as opposed to Judaism